(bêlements)
- Des moutons, accompagnés
de leur bergère, remplacent
les assourdissantes tondeuses
à gazon à essence dans ce parc
du nord-est de Montréal.
ANNIE CLOUTIER, bergère,
Biquette-Écopâturage
- Les moutons sont très utiles
pour tondre le gazon.
Ils fertilisent le sol aussi.
Ils font pas de compactage
comme peuvent le faire des...
la machinerie lourde,
des supertondeuses.
Ça fait pas de bruit.
- Cette méthode d'entretien
écologique s'appelle
l'écopaturage urbain.
Ce n'est pas nouveau à Montréal;
des expériences comme celles-là
ont déjà eu lieu il y a quelques
années au parc Maisonneuve
et au parc Pélican, entre
autres.
(exclamations de joie)
Et l'activité a aussi un volet
éducatif.
CAROLINE BOURGEOIS, mairesse,
arrondissement RDP-PAT
- C'est pas un projet
de zoo, c'est pas un projet
de ferme. C'est vraiment de...
un projet, oui, éducatif.
Les réactions sont
extraordinaires, là, déjà,
depuis l'arrivée des moutons.
C'est une belle facon aussi de
se reconnecter avec la nature,
avec même notre passé agricole.
Donc, je sens beaucoup, beaucoup
d'enthousiasme et beaucoup de
fierté de la part des citoyens.
- C'est bon pour la mentalité
pour tout le monde, parce
qu'avec la COVID, là, ça...
- T'aimes ça, les moutons?
- Oui, j'aime les moutons.
- Oui?
- Oui!
- Oui.
(bêlements)
- Et j'aimerais ça,
éventuellement, qu'ils mettent
plus d'animaux. Ça serait le fun
pour les enfants.
- Ça crée un événement
à Rivières-des-Prairies!
C'est bien!
(rire)
- C'est un lignifiant social
qui permet de calmer les gens.
On voit tout de suite les
sourires des gens quand ils
arrivent à proximité. Ils voient
les moutons, bon, il y a
des incrédules, mais aussi,
les gens sont super contents.
Bon, ils disent "c'est pour
les enfants", mais on voit
les adultes qui sourient
tout autant.
- Un projet pilote de quatre
semaines peu coûteux pour
les contribuables et bénéfique
pour la planète, et sans doute
aussi pour le moral.
- Une bonne sortie, une bonne
pause dîner pour quelqu'un
qui travaille de la maison.
C'est très, très beau.
- Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada,